[APPLAUSE]
Good evening, everyone.
And thank you for
having me back.
I gave a lecture yesterday
to a 12-plus audience
forward focused on the
Cold Atom Laboratory.
So you can ask me some
questions during the break
if you'd like to at the
very end of the talk.
But the talk today
will be focused
on the future of
green transportation,
specifically focused
on the Hyperloop,
which is a technology
development that I'm
working on now as
part of my day job
as senior vice president
of systems engineering
at Virgin's Hyperloop One.
And then I am here
in my capacity
as a professor or research
professor at the University
of Southern California, where
I work in the Astronautics
and Space Technology department.
I'm very happy to be here.
I participated in the
Christmas Lectures,
I think, about three
years ago with Kevin Fong
on space exploration.
And then I gave a
lecture in, I think,
2016 on the exploration of Mars.
So this is my third time
here, and it's always
a pleasure to be able to come
and visit London and Great
Britain.
And I'm actually born
in Great Britain.
I was born in Scotland.
And my mum actually
lives up in Southport.
So it's always a fun
time to come here.
Although I have an
American accent,
I do also still have
a British passport.
But just to give you a little
bit of a background about me,
my degrees are all in aerospace
engineering, bachelors,
masters, and PhD.
And my passion has always
been space exploration.
And ironically there's British
connection there as well.
When I was six years of
age on public television,
they had reruns of this very
odd science fiction programme
called Doctor Who.
And at the time, it
was Tom Baker episodes
that were airing.
And it was actually
my inspiration
from watching science fiction
and watching the doctor
sort of explore
alien worlds and be
very intelligent on
everything from zoology
to engineering to medicine that
made me think that I would like
to be like that person
one day, and that's
what made me become an engineer
So people are motivated
by different things
to become engineers.
Some people were motivated
by science fiction.
Some people are motivated purely
by the space programme or try
to make the world
a better place.
And that's essentially what I
like to do with the technology
that I develop.
And the reason why that's
relevant and germane
here is that all of that
passion is for space exploration
and exploring Mars and exploring
deep space with propulsion
technologies and rovers
that lands on other worlds.
As an engineer and
as a leader, I also
have a desire to help society.
And so when I was
given the opportunity
to help work on developing a
green transportation technology
solution, which
is the Hyperloop,
I couldn't turn that down.
Because if you can
use your engineering
skills and your
leadership skills
to help solve the problem
which is climate change, which
is global warming, by taking a
traditional internal combustion
engine type technology,
whether that be related to cars
or airplanes, and shift it over
to something which is green,
relying off the
grid power, that's
one way that you can make a
difference as an engineer.
So I worked about 16 years
of my career working for NASA
on the developments of
spacecraft and spacecraft
technology.
And so for the
past year I've been
focused on the development
of the Hyperloop,
which is the bulk of the
talk that we have here today.
And that does kind of
couple to this graphic,
which is obviously more
related to planetary science.
But these three
planets are actually
known as the
terrestrial planets.
The one on the left is Venus.
The one in the middle
obviously is Earth.
And the one on
the right is Mars.
And the reason why this
image is very telling
is in it the formation
of the solar system,
these three planets were
actually very similar
to each other in terms
of having an atmosphere
and in terms of having water
on the surface of the planet.
But right now only we are in
the Goldilocks zone in the sense
that we still have appreciable
water on the surface,
and we have a comfortable
temperature on the surface,
and we have a thick atmosphere.
Mars, on the other
hand, is essentially
a desert planet with
no appreciable water
on the surface and atmospheric
pressure of about 1%
of what we have here on Earth.
And Venus, on the other hand,
has a surface temperature
of 475 degrees centigrade and
an atmospheric pressure of 100
atmospheres.
And so something happened during
the course of these planets'
evolution which caused them
to deviate very much from what
they were to begin with.
And what that means
is that climate change
is a planetary phenomena and can
happen for different reasons.
The theory for Mars is that
it experienced an impact
with some kind of
asteroidal body, which
disrupted its magnetic field
because the core was impacted
and shattered.
And then in-space radiation
ripped off the atmosphere.
That's a hypothesis.
And for Venus, we don't
actually know what happened,
but we do know
that it experienced
a runaway greenhouse gas effect,
which then boiled the oceans,
created this thick atmosphere,
and created the incredibly
difficult conditions
for any type of life
to exist on the surface today.
And so as engineers, we can help
scientists make measurements
to test hypotheses to understand
how climate change happens.
But also, as engineers, we
can create new technologies
to solve climate change here
on Earth by reducing our carbon
footprint.
And so this is what leads,
then, to science fiction,
the Hyperloop.
And so the Hyperloop
is a concept
that came to a lot of notoriety
in around the 2011 to 2013
time frame because
Elon Musk proposed
with a white paper back
in 2008, as an alternative
to a high-speed rail
system in California,
that you could use
a Hyperloop instead,
which would be new
technology, more efficient,
more cost effective.
But the Hyperloop has existed
in the minds and visionaries
of the science fiction world
for many, many decades.
And so as early,
in my experience,
as watching reruns
of the Jetsons,
you see people travelling
through tubes at high speeds.
And some of the images that
you see here are also from
the science fiction literature,
showing you basically aircraft,
or not aircraft, but craft
travelling through tubes
at high speed.
So science fiction does
serve as an impetus,
does serve as an innovation
for many of the technologies
that we have.
Great example would
be the cell phone.
The Motorola flip
phone originally
was shown by Spock and Kirk
in Star Trek in the 1960s.
And then in the 1980s
and 1990s, the tablets
that were used in Star
Trek Next Generation
are now the technology
that we use today.
So even though science
fiction may not
provide the technological
blueprint for how
to make these devices, it does
provide the vision of ways
that these technologies
can benefit society.
And so the Hyperloop
is another example
of that, of ways that you can
solve a mass transportation
solution using a
new technology set.
And of course, it's
the job of the engineer
to figure out how to do that.
And sometimes in life
you do get things,
which is people say,
well, that can't be done.
Perfect example of that
is back in the late 1800s,
it was said that
heavier-than-air flying
machines are impossible.
And Lord Kelvin
actually was the person
who came out and said that.
And low and behold, you
have the Wright brothers
showing the demonstration
of heavier-than-air flying
machines, right?
Our travel today is basically
aircraft travel, transatlantic,
transpacific over
continents, all facilitated
by the work of
engineering geniuses
over the course of time.
And it does impact our society
in very important ways.
And of course, for
any new technology,
by a show of hands, who here
has seen the movie The Martian?
I'd say about 50% of you.
And so The Martian
is a great movie
if you're an engineering fan.
It actually goes
to great lengths
to describe the
calculations which
are done to show
how he could survive
on the surface of the planet
in many different ways.
But kind of the emphasis here
is that you can use science,
and you can use engineering
to get herself out
of a difficult situation.
So I think it's
kind of motivational
from that perspective.
And then my favourite
quote, I would say,
of all time is from
Theodore von Karman,
who's the father
of modern rocketry,
describing the difference
between science
and engineering, which science
is the study of what is.
And engineering
builds what will be.
And the scientists
explorers, and the engineer
creates the world which
has never existed before.
And so I think
this is showing you
how you can use the tools of
science, the tools of math,
to create these new technologies
to perhaps make money, but,
hopefully, perhaps to make
the world a better place
and a cleaner place
and a greener place.
And I think that is
motivational for many people.
So how does that tie
into the Hyperloop?
Well, just downstairs in the
Royal Institution basement
are a whole series
of laboratories
which cover the discoveries
of electromagnetics
and condensed metaphysics going
on for the past several hundred
years.
It's our fundamental
physics understanding
of electronic magnetism
which actually facilitates
the technologies that
go into the Hyperloop,
whether it be vacuum
technology in order to get down
to low pressures,
or whether it is
a linear electric
motor, which makes
use of the principles
of electromagnetism
to be able to levitate the
system and propel it forward.
So it is these fundamental
physics principles
which have enabled the
engineering solutions
that you see all across
the economic sectors,
and specifically in the
case of a Hyperloop system,
or a maglev
transportation system,
such as the maglev train,
are the core behind how
that's done.
And with any new
technology challenge,
you do need to have a customer.
You do need to have a reason.
And so transportation has been
revolutionary in our society.
And so looking at that
from a historical context,
go back 3,000 BC
is the first time
that the wheel was invented.
In 3,500 BC, the wheel was
invented for the purpose
of making pottery.
A couple of hundred years
later, it was decided, well,
we can actually use the
wheel to move objects
or to move chariots.
And so one can only imagine
how much it changed society
to be able to move goods
and services on the backs
of chariots using wheels
as opposed to not having
wheeled surface.
And so that was the first
transportation evolution
of our modern society.
Move forward many hundreds
years of years later,
the Industrial Revolution.
The Industrial Revolution
was facilitated largely due
to rail service, the ability
to once again transport
goods and services and
across large distances, which
allowed society to expand
over large land masses.
Move forward another
100 years or so,
personal mobility with the
internal combustion engine,
actually having individual cars
that could be driven around,
giving you
point-to-point service,
never has existed before.
All of a sudden, you
can get from point A
to point B. You can
connect villages.
You can connect cities.
You can connect states.
You can connect large
land masses across Europe
with the means of personal
mobility services.
And of course, the
most revolutionary one
which has happened in
the past 100 years or so
is the global
connectivity, which
is enabled by airplane transit,
which, once again, goes back
to the Wright brothers.
And so the interesting
thing, though,
is that we have not had a
transportation revolution
in over 100 years, right?
Flight was over 100 years ago.
And so nothing has
happened since then.
So now the time
is right for that.
But the other thing
about transportation
is that transportation networks
can also lead to waste.
So if you have congestion,
that will lead to delays.
And those delays can actually be
translated into lots of money,
right?
So if you're trying to transport
goods from point A to point B,
and you have to sit at the dock,
you have to sit at the port,
you have to sit at
the airport, you
can't get your goods transited.
You're actually losing money.
And so because money is what
makes the world go round,
being able to come up with a
way to facilitate transportation
so you can reduce those
delays is really important.
And then congestion, similarly,
in ports, in airports,
and on docks is a
problem in terms
of being able to get
goods to be transferred.
And all of these things, once
again, translate into money.
So if you can come up with a
new technology solution which
solves somebody else's
distribution problem,
all of a sudden you
have a group of people
who would be willing to
pay for this new service
to facilitate this new
mode of transportation.
And so you do need a
reason, a business case,
to be able to generate these
technologies in other cases.
And if we look at this in
a little bit more detail,
we can actually look at
some hard-core numbers which
tell us why there's a problem.
There's an expected
two-times increase
in port volume over the
course of the next 10,
20 years or so, right?
So how are we going
to solve that?
We're already at
congestion the ports.
And we're going to have
even more goods trying
to push through.
Therefore, we have a
congestion problem.
There's an expected 80% increase
in passenger miles to be
travelled.
And that's going to be more
congestion on the roads.
That's also going to
be more pollution.
So we need another way of
getting people from point A
to point B which
doesn't rely on cars.
And as more of the
developing world
wants to have a better
transportation solution,
hopefully we don't want to put
more cars on the road, which,
once, again, can lead to more
congestion, more pollution.
And then there's also an
expected and anticipated 88%
increase in freight over the
course of the next 20 years
or so.
Once again, this
has to be mitigated
to be able to solve the problems
of a growing global economy.
So what is the solution?
You could make a bigger airport.
But that usually doesn't address
the overall interoperability
solution in order to
make it efficient.
You could add more rail lines.
But if you're using
old technology,
you're probably going to
be consuming more land, not
really moving things
at much faster speed.
You could make wider highways.
That's usually quite difficult
because land availability
is somewhat limited.
So if you can come up
with something else which
disrupts this way of doing
transportation solutions,
that could be a good thing.
And then if you look at
the wider economic sector,
you can take a look at
other technologies which
have been developed, which could
facilitate a new transportation
solution.
And so the obvious one there
is the information technology
revolution, being
able to transmit
large quantities of
data over the internet,
for example, over
Wi-Fi, over RF.
So if you have a
transportation system which
could be facilitated
by the IT revolution,
then you can have two things
working synergistically
together to improve that
transportation bottleneck
that we see today.
So because of that, you
can make the argument that
now is the time for a
transportation revolution
which utilises new
technologies, such as autonomy
and the ability to transfer
large packets of information
and coupling that to a
transportation system.
And that's where we believe
the Hyperloop can come in.
And how that translates
is that you want something
that can operate
at a faster speed.
Because the way
that you eliminate
the time associated
with a distance
is to move at a faster speed.
And of course, we're not talking
about the speed of light.
But we're talking
about something
which is on the order of
faster than airline travel,
for example.
And then you have to
come back and think
about what it is that your
customers would actually
want from you.
And what everybody wants
from a customer perspective
is they want something which
is cost effective, right?
You're not going to want to
have to pay an arm and a leg
for something.
It has to be
affordable, which means
it has to be in the range of
airline travel or rail travel.
It has to be safe.
Any new transportation
system which is proposed
should, by definition, if
reliant on new technology,
should be safer than prior
modes of transportation.
It should have a lower
environmental impact
because everybody
around the world today
sees the importance
and the need for this.
And it should support
larger capacities
than are currently handled
by current transportation
solutions in order to address
the congestion for both goods
and for people.
And so any system
which is proposed
has to facilitate that.
And so what I'll talk about now
is specifically the Hyperloop
transportation system.
And so in this video here you
can see an artist's conception
of what a Hyperloop
passenger vehicle looks
like, which is
what we call a pod,
holds about 20
people per vehicle.
Inside of it, it has a
linear electric motor.
That linear electric motor
is its propulsion system,
which allows it to go
forward at fast speeds,
operating off of
grid-based power.
And using a linear
electric motor
is no different from a
rotation electric motor
that you would have
an electric vehicles.
You simply spread
out the platform,
and you still have the same
interaction of the Lorentz
force to give you
acceleration, using
the interaction of electric
current with magnetic fields.
The true key concept
of the Hyperloop,
though, is that
it operates inside
of a vacuum tube,
which means that you
reduce the ambient pressure.
And so instead of
operating at 1 atmosphere,
you're operating
at an equivalent
of 120,000 feet in
altitude, or about 0.1%
of atmospheric pressure.
All that is done inside
of a vacuum structure,
in which the air is removed
with a series of pumps.
And then finally,
the element which
is also of critical importance
for operational efficiency
is the use of a
levitation engine.
So you use electromagnetic
forces to levitate the vehicle
off of the track.
So you don't get frictional
wear and tear on wheels,
as you would with
traditional rolling stock
for rail-based systems.
And because you're operating
at such fast speeds,
up to 1,000 kilometres per hour,
roughly 700 miles per hour,
the system has to be autonomous
because there is no way
that a human being in the loop
could operate accelerate-- not
acceleration, but to be able
to ensure that you get rid
of any bad safety scenarios.
You have to have autonomous
operation of the pods
relative to each other once,
which, once again, relies
on new technology.
That's an artist's
conception of what
this system could look like.
And I'll show you the video
of the system we've actually
built so you can see how we
turned that into reality.
But using new technology
to improve efficiency
is actually nothing new.
So autonomy is being coupled
to the automotive industry
as we speak.
And so many cars that
people purchase today
already have trial runs
of autonomous systems,
where they have
lidars on board which
allow you to detect whether
it be some kind of obstacle
in your path, or
vehicles next to you.
Or if you haven't
braked in time in front
of the vehicle in
front of you, the car
will do the braking for you.
So car-based autonomous
systems, using hazard avoidance,
are actually very
complicated because you
have many unknowns which
are coming into your path.
Even in this graphic, you can
see you can have a bicycle.
You can have a person
crossing the road.
You can have an object
which falls in front of you.
Your car has to be able to react
to that with its autonomous
system for hazard avoidance.
For a Hyperloop-type
system, you're
in a controlled environment.
You're, by definition,
in a micro climate.
That controlled
environment actually
allows you to only have
one directional control.
And basically your
hazard avoidance problem
becomes easier because there
can't be any people in there.
There can't be any
objects in there
because it is that
controlled environment.
And then because you're
operating at such fast speeds,
you're enabling
on-demand departure
for people within the
vehicle's going from point A
to point B and direct
to destination.
But the basic concept of a
Hyperloop pod is a pressurised
cabin.
And so you can think of a
Hyperloop pod as an aircraft
without wings.
And so it is a pressurised cabin
because on the exterior you
have a lower
pressure environment.
And so the pressure in
the vacuum structure
is about 0.1% to 1% of
atmospheric pressure.
And the pressure inside
the passenger vehicle
is about 1 atmosphere.
So it has a larger
delta pressure across it
than a traditional
aircraft cabin would have.
But it's actually within
the realm of possibility
and easily designed using
typical aircraft structures.
So the way that
you have to do this
in a way which is cost efficient
is you have to innovate.
And sometimes-- I work for the
government for about 16 years--
it can be more
expensive when you
have the government innovate.
So if you can use the startup
methodology or the startup
mentality of being very
driven and very focused
using an open office,
collaborative environment,
you can actually
implement a new technology
solution a little bit easier.
And so there's been a lot of
emphasis in media culture,
at least in the
United States, where
you use startup environment to
be able to push things forward.
Whether you think about an
Uber or a Google or a Facebook,
those are very similar
to a startup environment.
So our company is
very much that.
We use the
entrepreneurial mindset.
We have a team of
about 300 engineers
and business strategists
working in downtown Los Angeles.
And we've come up with a new
technology solution which
focuses on the
business case, which
I talked about briefly,
and, of course,
on the technology development
and the implementation
of new technologies
to facilitate
this mass transportation
solution at high speeds
and reasonable affordable cost.
This is a graphic you may not
get since you're in the UK.
But one of the
difficulties associated
with any mass
transportation system
is the cost of infrastructure,
literally, the cost of laying
bridges, of putting up columns.
And that represents a
large portion of the cost,
regardless of what your
transportation system is.
So you also have to
disrupt the infrastructure
cost, which is very
difficult. So here's
my joke on The Village People.
Not everybody gets it.
But how do you do that?
You do a little bit of
a vertical integration
model, which means that you
come up with all the prototypes
yourself and the preliminary
design for all those prototypes
yourself.
And so for our company,
what we did is we
created a Hyperloop
factory, where we actually
fabricate and test
out welding techniques
of the middle tubes, which are
required to create that vacuum
structure.
And so here you can see a
portion of the steel tube
that we created for a Hyperloop
test facility in Las Vegas.
And so when you do
the fabrication,
when you do the
design work yourself,
when you do the installation
assembly, the testing,
you actually learn how to put
one of these systems together
in the most cost-effective,
time-efficient way possible.
And then you implement that
in the field for the project
specifics that you want to do.
And so we also created a
Hyperloop test facility,
and so we were able
to get a site out
in Northeast Las Vegas,
just about 45 minutes
from the strip.
This was in 2016.
We started to lay the
column structures in place
for the elevated hyper structure
which is going to go above it.
Over the course of
a period of a year,
we actually built a
full Hyperloop system
of a length of half a kilometre.
And so I'll show you
a short video which
covers some of the work there.
But we basically started off
by levelling ground, putting
in the columns, then installing
the vacuum structure tubes,
and then installing the
vacuum pumping station.
And I'll walk you through
that video for the next one.
So here you can see
a segment of tube.
Here you can see the
columns that are in place.
You can see a rapid timeline
of the columns going up.
We have a mission
control centre,
where the tubes are tested.
You can see a portion of
our vehicle being built up,
once again, where
the tube in place,
and Richard Branson,
our chairman.
And then finally, you
can see our passenger
pod, which is being built up.
And then you'll see
the final system
being installed into the
vacuum tube into the site
off to the side.
So this is the full
facility that was built.
What you see here is a half
kilometre section of tube
open at the very end.
The pod travels
through this tube.
It has a total length
of half a kilometre.
It spends half the portion
of the tube accelerating up
to speed, coasts
for a little bit,
and then decelerates
on the other side.
So you can do our
speed demonstration
and operational demonstration.
What you also see in this image
here is a pumping station.
So we use commercially
available pumps
to get the pressure
down to about 0.1%
of atmospheric pressure.
And the reason
for that is having
a lot lower
aerodynamic drag allows
you to go to very high
speeds at a lower energy
cost, which is the prior
premise of the Hyperloop.
And so that single
pumping station
can actually pump out
a tube about four times
the length of what you see here.
So we built the facility so
that it can evolve and grow
over time.
This is a pod that we developed
for our test facility.
So this represents
probably about 80%
of full scale of
what we would have
for our commercial
production system.
The unique features of
the pod that we developed
is we made it out of
a composite, which
allows it to be very lightweight
but also very strong.
We also used 3D printing
for the structure,
which, once again, allows it to
be lightweight but very strong.
And so these passenger
pods you can think of,
as I said before, as an airplane
without wings because they
have a levitation engine.
And they have a
limiter electric motor,
which allows them to move
forward and efficiently
along the track.
So this particular
test programme we did,
we weren't testing
the pressurised pod.
But the next stage of the design
that we go to, we will also
test a pressurised pod.
But these panels are
designed to carry
roughly 20 people in total.
And the architecture
that we're using
is many smaller vehicles just
basically going continuously
through the tubes
basically along a highway.
So it's slightly different
from a rail system,
where you would have
stopping and starting
along the main line.
Here you would have a main
line going each direction.
And people getting off
for a given station
would exit the main line and
go to their final destination,
which allows you to have
a constant high speed
and no deceleration in
the main line, which
allows you to be more efficient
in terms of your energy
consumption.
So right here what you see
is the pod being installed
into the vacuum system.
And so once the pod is installed
and the door is closed,
the tube is pumped down to the
0.1% of atmospheric pressure.
And then we use the
linear electric motor
and the levitation engine
to accelerate it, allow it
to coast, and decelerate
it to do our demonstration.
And whenever you do these kinds
of technology demonstrations,
they're done primarily for
the purpose of testing out
all of your models, testing
out all of your designs
and all of your prototyping
so that you can implement that
in the next phase of the
design, as you shift over
to production.
And so with all modern
aerospace systems,
the use of computational
fluid dynamics
and the use of
structural modelling
to be able to capture
the interaction
of the electromagnetic forces,
the aerodynamic forces,
and the electromagnetic forces.
So this very last video
I'm going to show you
is an operational
Hyperloop system
that we have in Las Vegas, which
is for technology demonstration
purposes.
So you can see the pod
moving inside the tube.
Is accelerating right now.
Oops.
You can see the other side
for the nose cone view.
So our architecture
here is that we
go to a much higher acceleration
profile for this technology
demonstration than we would
use in an actual system.
And the reason for that
is so that we can get up
to peak speed in
a shorter distance
than you would for an
operational system.
So it allows us to do a
higher speed demonstration
in a shorter track.
And to date, our maximum
speed demonstration
has been 387
kilometres per hour,
which is not our
peak speed that we
intend to go to in operation.
But it's the maximum speed
that we can demonstrate
in this length of track.
And this gives
you a view of what
the entire track looks like in
our Northeast Las Vegas test
facility.
And so the other
interesting thing to note
is that because
we're out testing
in the desert, in the
desert, you actually
experience extreme
temperature swings, right?
So during the daytime,
you can get up
to 120 degrees Fahrenheit.
And in the evening
in the wintertime,
you can get to below freezing.
And so that large
temperature differential
happens to be a external
environmental condition that is
taxing on a system like this.
So this technology
development facility
allows us to look at
environmental effects as well.
So the other unique
aspect of a Hyperloop
is the passenger experience.
So if you are to travel
in a rail system,
you experience basically
bumping along the tracks.
You experience if there's
any kind of, maybe,
small debris on the tracks.
You would feel that as
you're going along at speed.
Similarly in an aircraft, when
you're going down the runway,
you will experience
bumping along the runway.
When you do your
initial takeoff,
you'll experience higher
acceleration forces.
When you're in
cruise an aircraft,
you'll experience
turbulence because you
can't control the environment
that you find yourself in.
The unique aspect of
a Hyperloop system
is that you control the
environment yourself.
And because the environment
essentially around the pod
is a vacuum, have
turbulence interactions.
You don't have any kind of
aerodynamic interaction.
So the ride is
actually quite smooth.
We plan to operate this
system at roughly a quarter G
for a maximum acceleration and
maximum deceleration, which,
once again, is within the
realm of any people mover
that you might
take in an airport
or in the realm of
any metro system
that you might ride in
any metropolitan area.
So the system itself is designed
to actually be very comfortable
for passengers within it.
So even though you're
travelling over long distances,
between 40 kilometres all the
way up to 1,000 kilometres,
you don't experience any of the
traditional discomfort that you
would experience in a
rail system or even with
an aircraft, for example.
And this gives you
sort of a mock-up view
of the facility that we
built for the Middle East
so that you get an idea of
what the passenger layout is
in terms of the seats.
So the most important
thing, I would say,
for developing a mass
transportation system
is to make it reliable,
to make it resilient,
and to make it
automated because this
allows it to be more cost
effective from an operational
sense.
It also allows it to have a
smaller environmental impact
wherever you plan to
implement it around the world.
And the other way
of looking at this
is basically shifting from a
linear to a circular economy.
And so a linear
economy is basically
where you don't have any
reuse of your raw materials.
You expend the raw material.
It goes into waste.
And you have to
re-initiate that cycle.
And that doesn't allow you
to be as environmentally
friendly as you could be.
So being able to shift over
to a circular economy, where
your raw materials, whether
it be steel, whether it
be composite structures, or
even whether it be batteries
or the materials
associated batteries,
if you can choose to
implement that supply
chain in a circular
sense, you can actually
have a smaller carbon footprint
over your entire supply chain.
And so that is also
the goal of what
we're doing at the Hyperloop.
And it's the goal
of many companies
that are actually
operating today.
So that's a way of thinking
about how your supply chain can
tie into other supply
chains so you can minimise
your environmental footprint.
And then I think if you think
about how the system is going
to be implemented because
the speeds are so fast,
you can actually connect
people and connect cities
over a period of time which
has been unheard of before.
That at a peak speed of
roughly up to 700 miles an hour
and up to 1,000
kilometres per hour,
you can connect
major urban regions
in less than 30 minutes.
So from the US side of things,
a very important corridor
for rail transit,
for example, is
between Washington,
DC, Boston, and New
York, which typically takes
many, many hours to go
between these cities.
With a Hyperloop system,
that new urban radius
would be around 30 minutes just
because of the incredibly fast
cruise speed that you
operate with a Hyperloop.
And similarly, if
a Hyperloop system
were to be implemented
in England between London
and the north of England, you're
looking at 30-minute transit
times between those locations.
And so it's kind
of amazing to think
about how this speed
simply does facilitate
a different way of thinking
about how you can connect
mega regions across
the world, whether it's
in Europe or in the Middle
East, in India, or in America.
And then for comparison,
we can take a look
at a system which could be
implemented in the United
States, where you could connect
80% of the United States
in five hours or less.
That's pretty
significant, right,
being able to reach all
of these urban centres
in a short period of time.
And even though I am not a
business person by training--
I'm an engineer-- you can think
of the induced demand which
will result in all of the
areas which are now serviced
by the Hyperloop because now
you can have people live there
and not have to worry about the
traditional delays of traffic
of being able to get from
their suburban location
into the urban centres where
their companies may be.
So how this system could be
implemented in the United
States is very
similar to the way
could be implemented across
Europe or across India
or across Asia or
the Middle East.
And although Hyperloop does not
address transatlantic travel
or transpacific travel,
it does address travel
over land masses,
and it does allow
you to do it in a much more
green way than you could
do with current aircraft systems
and with current rail type
systems because of the
lower energy cost associated
with operating in this drag-free
environment and, of course,
this low-friction environment,
as you're levitating the pod.
So it does have the ability to
connect the planet in a very
different way.
And every project
which gets implemented
will have an international
consortium of partners.
And those partners
could actually
implement those projects
around the world.
And they'll learn from
each implementation
and allow it to even go
off more cost effectively
in the second or
third implementations.
And so it is definitely a
future transportation mode
which is going to
happen probably
within the next 5 to 10
years or so around the world.
So to wrap up the talk, though--
I think I'm a little
bit over time--
I want to talk about two new
modes of transportation which
are up and coming.
And one is flying cars.
And so in my capacity
as a research professor,
I do research in areas
of urban mobility.
And so one of those is
an autonomous air taxis.
And so there is a
system that we're
looking at developing
specifically focused
on the autonomy aspect.
And so I'd like to go
back to The Jetsons,
because this is the first time
that The Jetsons was showed
in the context of flying
cars, and show you
the concept of a flying
car, which essentially
is an autonomous helicopter with
automated takeoff and landing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So that is a concept.
And they're developing
many concepts
around the world with
different companies.
And the goal here is
aerial urban transport.
So for some cases,
a Hyperloop system
is actually only valuable
for longer distances
because you have to be
able to accelerate up
to peak speed, coast for
a bit, and decelerate
to make the energy
efficiency worthwhile.
So when you're looking
at shorter distance
travel within urban locations,
for example, or urban centres,
you want to have
something which is
more like a metro-based system.
But you could have
something which
is also above the ground,
which is an aerial transport
urban system.
And because of the advances
in battery technology, all
of a sudden the energy
densities are becoming such
that you could have
electrified aircraft certainly
over short distance trips,
which a helicopter would need
to take from a
endurance perspective,
but even over travel
over long land masses.
So by being able to
electrify aircraft,
you can actually have a
lower carbon footprint
for aircraft travel,
whether it be
a rotor craft or traditional
higher speed craft.
And so that's a way
that you can actually
address urban transport in a
lower carbon footprint sense.
Now, the other challenge,
of course, with flying
is that if you have too
many airplanes in the air,
you can have an air
traffic control nightmare,
and you could have
safety issues.
So what you have
to shift over to
for aerial airborne transport
is an autonomously controlled
and scheduled system.
And so that's what
will facilitate
being able to get more people
in the pipeline in terms
of whatever flight path they'd
need to be on and then get back
to their final destination.
And so there is a huge
amount of research
going on in that area in terms
of the autonomy and scheduling.
And then finally,
what you can do
to eliminate
ground-based congestion
by getting cars off
the road, because
of these urban aerial
transport systems,
can actually address a lot of
the safety risks associated
with automotive systems
and autonomy used in cars.
So the very final part of
the future of transportation
is supersonic air travel.
And supersonic air travel
has existed obviously
for fighter jets.
It did exist for the Concorde.
But it was not a cost-efficient
way of operating, I guess,
back when the Concorde existed.
And so that has to be improved.
And then the other challenge is
that all the technologies which
are being developed do still
have associated with them
a sonic boom or the acoustic
disturbance associated
with supersonic flight.
And so basically, the
regulations for the FAA
and the regulations for
any aviation authority
all over the world
is that you can't
have that kind of acoustic
disturbance over land
masses, which means that
supersonic flight, which
is being proposed, is
limited to basically
over-the-water travel,
which doesn't represent
the bulk of long
distance travel and also
requires you to go subsonic
before you actually approach
areas where people are living.
So that happens to be
a technology limitation
associated with supersonic
air travel because
of the restrictions associated
with people not wanting
to be disturbed by a sonic
boom, which makes sense.
And so that basically
prevents supersonic flight
over 70% of air travel,
right, because of the fact
that you can be
limited over water.
So it's only good for
transatlantic, transpacific,
for a portion of it.
And you have to
have a system really
to be able to be
autonomously controlled,
same thing for Hyperloops, which
have to operate at high speeds.
You also have to have aircraft
operate these high speeds, also
autonomously controlled.
You can still have
a pilot in the loop.
But you probably don't want
to have two or three pilots
in the loop.
And if you take a look at the
projections of how many pilots
there exist today, there
aren't enough pilots now
to support the amount of air
traffic which is planned.
So being able to shift
airplanes over to autonomy
also makes a lot of sense.
And so that's where we're
headed with supersonic travel.
And so one of the research
projects I'm working on at USC
is actually the design
of a new aircraft, which
does have a technology
solution to reduce
the intensity of the
acoustic disturbance that
comes about as a result of the
sonic boom which is generated
by the supersonic environment.
And although it
is IP restricted,
the goal is you can come up
with a wing geometry, a wing
curvature, which interacts
with the exhaust plumes
of the engines, which are
providing you with your thrust,
in order to mitigate
that disturbance.
And the interesting thing is
there is analogy from the Mars
programme, where the Mars
landing systems actually have
engines which point
towards the ground.
They have supersonic
exhaust plumes.
And depending on how you design
the curvature of the nozzle
and how it interacts
with the ground beneath,
you can actually dissipate
a lot of the energy
in those exhaust plumes.
So there is a large
area of research
possible between the
aerodynamics of the wings
and the interaction of the
aerodynamics coming out
of the exhaust plumes
where you can help
to mitigate that
sonic boom, reduce
the overall acoustic
disturbance,
and get it to levels which
then allows you to fly
within limits the FAA
imposes or whatever
the British authorities
or European authorities
would impose on people.
And so that actually
would facilitate
the use of supersonic
air travel in that case.
And so that's one final
aspect that we're working on.
And we did a 3D
print of the vehicle.
Now, the good news
is that you don't
have to build the
aircraft and fly
it to make sure that it works.
You can use computational
fluid dynamics.
And so when you're operating
a supersonic regime,
it is a little bit more
of a difficult regime
to be able to capture
the interactions in.
But modern-day techniques
looking at turbulence
and having good
models for turbulence
enables you to get the
performance that you need out
of the wing and show ahead
of time that it works.
You then make a model like
this for a wind tunnel.
You wouldn't make
it out of plastic.
You would make it
probably out of metallic.
And then you would validate your
computational fluid dynamics
simulations by testing the
model in that environment
to show that it works.
So this, I would say,
is going to happen
in the next 15 to 20 years.
But the far future is
slightly different.
So the far future,
I do believe, is
going to take us
off of planet Earth
and send us to other locations.
And so I believe what's
in the far future
is for humans to
travel in space.
And I think what you've
seen over the course
of the past five to seven
years or so with the advent
of SpaceX, Blue
Origin, Sierra Nevada
are companies who are developing
lower cost access to space
and then developing
vehicles to be
able to get you
from Earth to Mars
and then eventually land
you on the surface of Mars.
So this particular vehicle,
which is being developed
by NASA, the Orion programme
or the Orion capsule,
is intended to take human
beings into deep space,
whether that's to land them on
the surface of the moon or send
them all the way up to an
asteroid or to land them
on Mars.
And so whether you agree
or like space travel,
there are many people
who are interested in it
for commercial purposes,
for space tourism purposes.
And so there's a huge shift
in the transportation sector
to develop space-based
technologies to enable
people to live on other worlds.
There's a whole
set of challenges
associated with that.
A lot of them is
associated with the energy
cost of being able to
defeat Earth's gravity well.
But the other, of
course, is being
able to slow down
and land safely
on the surface of another world.
And then after you get
to the other world,
the next important
thing is to be
able to survive there and set
up colonies on other planets.
And so there is
work being done now
at NASA and in space
agencies around the world
to understand what kind
of life support systems
are necessary to put yourself on
the surface of another planet.
And this is an example
of a habitation module
which is being tested to show
that human beings can actually
live safely on the
surface of Mars
not from the perspective
of looking at the radiation
environment, but from
the perspective of how
are you able to regulate how
much water you consume, how are
you able to grow your own
food, how are you able
to provide that sort
of closed loop system
so that you can survive
for periods of nine months
to two years on the
surface of another planet.
And so all the technologies--
we have to do a much better
job how we're doing it here
actually [INAUDIBLE] that point.
And that leads to the very
final point, which is basically
in-situ resource utilisation.
And so we've all thought
about recycling, right?
If we compost, we're able
to return our plant matter
and make it into soil.
If we recycle our metals,
if we recycle our plastics,
we're able to put it
back into that pipeline.
But ultimately, if you're going
to travel to another world,
you actually have to use the
resources on that other world.
You can't bring
everything with you .
And we kind of have to
do that here at home.
And so one of the ways
that you can tie this
in to a rail-type system
or a Hyperloop-type system
is to utilise solar
panels, right,
on the exterior of the tube or
on the exterior of the track
where the system is going.
And so there is a desire
to be able to implement
that type of closed-loop powered
system for a Hyperloop system
in the near future.
And if you can somehow
couple that to,
in some cases,
where you don't have
solar panels, the
use of trees to shade
to have more regulated
thermal environment,
that's something that
we should also consider.
But in-situ resource utilisation
for going to the moon,
for example, even the
Apollo astronauts used that.
They actually filled
bags with sand,
put it over where they were to
provide additional radiation
protection.
The same thing could
be done on Mars.
But that's something that
we have to think about.
Our mindset essentially
has to change
as we get to the fact that we're
hitting the edge of what we can
handle in terms of
fossil fuels and in terms
of what the impact
is on climate change.
So all the
technologies that we're
looking at today, whether
it be a Hyperloop which
is using grid-based power,
which hopefully is coming
from renewables, whether we're
looking at autonomous air
taxis which are using
electrified batteries, which
get their power from
grid-based power which can come
from renewables, or for
supersonic planes which
eventually could be
sort of a hybrid system
and having electrification
for some of the power
but still a backup of an
internal combustion engine,
are ways that we can have a
greener, more efficient future
for transporting ourselves
around the planet.
And so the very last thing I
wanted to talked about today
is women in STEM.
And so I was able to work on
a book with Libby Jackson.
It's called Galaxy of Her Own.
She's from the
European Space agency.
She's an engineer there who
works on mission operations.
And in 2017, she released a
book here on the UK and Europe.
And then she released it in
the US under s different name,
which is Galaxy Girls, which
is the story of 15 women
and their roles in
the space programme.
And for any of you who have
daughters or young women
in your life who might be
interested in studying science
or engineering, this is a
very inspirational book.
And it has basically
the stories of 15 women,
from Sally Ride to
Mae Jamison to all
of the most recent astronauts
are all in this book.
And I do encourage
you to consider
getting a copy for your local
school or your local library
or the women and the girls
that you have in your life
because it can be
quite inspirational.
And that is something
which is important to me.
And as I go around
giving public lectures
on the topic of a the
Hyperloop, on the topic of space
exploration, I always
like to encourage
people to think about how
they can take what they've
learned these
lectures and spread it
to other people in their lives.
But for the last, I,
guess 15 minutes or so,
I can take questions
from the audience.
And I will actually try
and find that graphic
that was missing before, too.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]